[Music]  are you in love  i hope so  but ask yourself this  when it happened  is any of it anything like you planned  is this person that now owns a huge part  of your life anything like you thought  it'd be  did they arrive when they were supposed  to  [Applause]  sometimes when i'm stressed i time  travel  i can't control it  if i make the mistake of loving someone  i don't know how many times i'm gonna  have to lose them  [Music]  it's not gonna happen now  maybe trying to hold on  okay hold on  so how long you been seeing claire from  time to time  i don't like him that he's gonna be your  best friend how's that even possible  it'd be nice if you at least appreciated  him i have loved him since i was six  years old no you loved him  [Music]  it's me claire i'm henry the same henry  someday  [Music]  why is claire crying you can't change  anything you couldn't even get married  [Music]  i miss you  i'm here now  [Music]  you